-Greta, welcome back
to the show.
-Thank you for having me.
-I'm so happy to have you.
You brought a little news,
exciting news for us.
-Yes.
I am with child.
-Yes, exactly!
[ Cheering and applause ]
The best!
[ Rimshot ]
Baby Number 2.
-Number 2.
-You are expecting
and thank you
for announcing it on our show.
-Yes. Well, I, actually,
I thought it would be --
I went to an event recently
and I wore something
that I thought everyone would be
so interested to know
that I was going to have
another child and nobody cared.
[ Laughter ]
And it didn't get reported on.
Turns out nobody's
paying attention to you.
[ Laughter ]
-No.
No, we are paying attention.
We're so happy for you.
This is going to be
Baby Harold's brother
or sister, yeah.
-Yes, yeah, yeah.
-He's four years old.
-Almost four, yes.
He's almost four, yeah.
-Oh, no, that's --
I can't believe it's so --
it happened so fast.
-I know.
-We've known each other
for a long time
and, now, you have babies.
-I know.
[ Laughter ]
-What does Baby Harold think
of this new baby?
-It's hard to know what
a three-year-old makes of things
that aren't existent, yet,
in front of him.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
He's --
I mean, he's beautifully
sophisticated, in some ways,
and then, in other ways,
he doesn't --
He asks, "What language do they
speak in New Jersey?"
[ Laughter ]
So.
-Yeah.
That's a good question,
actually.
[ Laughter ]
What did you tell him? Yeah.
-Yeah.
I mean, we were looking
across the Hudson River
and he said,
"And what language do they speak
in New Jersey?"
[ Laughter ]
And I thought, "Oh, that's --
I wish I had a wonderful answer
for you in your queries."
So, the idea of a child
is sort of.
-But he said something
very deep to you
-Yes.
-that made me --
I wanted you to say
because I really like this.
It made me laugh.
He was having a bath.
-He has -- He loves bubbles.
Like all three-year-olds
love bubbles.
[ Laughter ]
But he gets very sad
when the bubbles go away
[ Laughter ]
and he starts welling up.
And then he looked at me
and he said,
"That's the nature of bubbles."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And I said, "Oh, that is --"
-That's the nature.
-That's the nature of bubbles.
And I was like, "Well, maybe --"
-That's deep.
-Yes. Maybe we'll understand.
-But yes.
-Oh, that's so cute.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-I'm so happy for you.
-I wanted to --
We've been talking about you,
weirdly, on the show
without you --
without your permission
because we're such fans of you.
I know you're --
you're directing "Barbie."
-Yes.
-Written and directed this.
-That's right.
Yes, I wrote it
with my partner, Noah...
-Yeah, we love Noah.
-and I directed it, yeah.
-And you directed this.
So, we had everyone on.
We've had Ryan Gosling on.
We had Margot Robbie on.
Talk about --
because this photo went out
-Oh, yes.
-and kind of just
the Internet went nuts.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, yes, yes. Yes.
-What did you think about this
when this --
-Well, first of all, I
just adore everybody who's
in this film
-Yeah.
-and I'm in that
very strange experience
of being a director editing,
which is I feel like I hang out
with them every day
and they don't feel that way
[ Laughter ]
because I'm alone
with footage of their face.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. So,
you think you're besties.
-Yeah, I'm like I feel like we
spend all day together.
But, no, that picture was
we'd shot most of the movie
in London
and then we went to L.A.
to shoot
and everything for us was so --
The cast was so committed.
Everybody gave everything
they had.
They really went for it.
It's like full, full commitment.
And then we realized,
in that moment, we were like,
"Oh, we look insane!"
[ Laughter ]
But we didn't know.
-No, if you're in the bubble
and everyone's dressed
like this.
-Yes. Then we were like,
[ Laughter ]
"This is normal."
-You go, "This is normal.
Yeah, this is what
everyone looks like."
And then you get
out and people are like,
"Wh-Wh-What?!"
-Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
So, it felt like --
And it was suddenly --
I --
But they were incredible.
They honestly --
-Did you know you were going
to direct this
or you were just hired
to write, at first, right?
-We were hired to write it
and I loved writing it
and Noah and I had the best time
writing it
and then I just love
Margot Robbie so much
and I got to know her
as a producer
because she also produced it
and she's a brilliant actress.
And then it just killed me
to think that anybody else
would get to hang out with her,
so I was like,
[ Laughter ]
"I have to. I have to.
-"Can I direct this?" Yeah.
-She's. my fave.
-And everyone cool is
in this, I just know.
-Yes.
-Also, Will Ferrell,
we had on the show.
-Issa Rae.
-I know Will isn't it.
[ Cheering ]
-Yeah. Oh, Issa Rae?
-Issa Rae, Simu Liu...
-Oh, yeah.
-...Ncuti Gatwa.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Whoo!
-Michael Cera.
-Oh, my gosh!
[ Cheering and whistling ]
-But this is later.
We'll do this later.
-Yeah, we'll do this all later.
-Later.
-Now, we have -- Yeah.
We have baby news.
You can't top baby news.
Except, we have to talk
about your movie
-Yes, yes, yes.
-as well, "White Noise."
-Congrats on the great
reviews already.
-Thank you.
-This is awesome.
Super fun movie.
-Yes.
-How did you, again,
get involved with this one?
-Well, my partner,
Noah Baumbach,
wrote and directed it
and it's based on a book,
"White Noise," by Don DeLillo,
which was written in 1985.
-Did you know the book?
-I did!
I read it when I was 19
and I loved it.
I thought it was outrageous
and hilarious
and it felt like
about everything.
-Yeah.
-And it's one of those books
that, at every moment,
it feels about right now.
And so --
-So, Noah's going,
"I'm going to direct this movie
and this is going to be great,"
and you go, "Phew,
it is going to be great."
And it's like,
"And who are you thinking about
for the lead, you know?"
And he's like,
"Well, Adam Driver."
"Yeah, and how about
the female lead?"
[ Laughter ]
Did you kind of go like,
slip your résumé?
-Yes, yes.
[ Laughter ]
-"I'd be perfect for this."
-He was actually
across the apartment.
He sort of called
to me and said,
"Who should play Babette?!"
And I said, "Obviously, me!"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah!
Exactly the way to do it!
"I should play Babette," yeah.
-But I think I -- You know,
I hadn't acted in a while
and I got -- you know,
it's nerve-wracking
and it's with Adam Driver
and Don Cheadle
-Yes!
-and really amazing actors.
-But you have that wig that
you're wearing, that is so --
-[ Laughs ]
Wait 'til you see this.
-The wig is great.
-This is one of your costars.
Look at this.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
I wish that's my hair.
-No, I mean, but this is
a very important part
of the character, though,
Babette.
-Don says,
about my character, he says,
"Your wife has important hair."
[ Laughter ]
And so I feel like,
as long as I had
the important hair, I'd be safe.
-You did.
You had the important hair.
You could pull --
You pulled this off, bud.
-Thank you.
-Yeah.
How do we set up the movie here,
"White Noise"?
-Well, "White Noise"
is a comedy.
It takes place in the 1980s
and it's about a...
typical family,
sort of slightly off,
but they're trying --
they're facing a disaster
and ignoring it,
which we might all know
something about.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, of course.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Greta Gerwig
in "White Noise."
Take a look at this.
-That stuff causes cancer
in laboratory animals,
in case you didn't know.
-You wanted me to chew
sugarless gum, Denise.
It was your idea.
-There was no warning
on the pack then.
Then they put a warning,
which I have a hard time
believing you didn't see.
-Either I chew gum with sugar
and artificial coloring
or I chew sugarless gum
that's harmful to rats.
It's up to you.
-Don't chew at all.
You ever think of that?
-Denise!
Steffie!
Either I chew gum or I smoke.
-Why not do both?
That's what you want, isn't it?
We all get to do what we want,
don't we?
-Unless we're not allowed to
because of our age and height.
-You're making a fuss
over nothing.
-I guess you're right.
Never mind.
Just a warning on the pack.
-Just rats.
-Just useless rodents.
Plus, I'd like to believe she
only chews two pieces a day,
the way she forgets things.
-What do I forget?
-It's alright.
Never mind.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Laughs, claps ]
Come on.
Greta Gerwig, everybody!
"White Noise" is
in select theaters now
and on Netflix December 30th.
Dane Cook joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.